und ich begrüße jetzt direkt in Moskau
unsere Russland kosmonentin Ina Ruck
herzlich willkommen Frau Ruck Frau Ruck
gibt es denn schon irgendwelche
Reaktionen in Moskau auf diesen Besuch
von US-Präsident bei den in der Ukraine
nein noch keine offiziellen Reaktion das
wäre auch sehr untypisch für den Kreml
solche Dinge lässt man erstmal liegen
kommentiert sie vielleicht ein Tag
später oder am Abend es wird sicherlich
auch Putin nicht so schnell was dazu
sagen wenn dann höchstens dann Sprecher
das wäre wirklich ganz untypisch wenn
man gleich darauf reagiert auf doch so
eine überraschende Nachricht die ja auch
nicht unbedingt eine gute Nachricht ist
für Russland wir haben Reaktionen
gesehen hier in den sozialen Medien bei
telegram-kanälen die er als sehr
kriminar bis hin zu sehr nationalistisch
gelten da wird dann tatsächlich sehr
hämisch über beiden gesprochen und
geschrieben dass der dass der quasi Opa
ist da noch sich dahin traut und so
solche Worte werden da benutzt aber nur
offizielle Reaktion nein gibt es
natürlich noch nicht
morgen wird ja eine große Rede des
russischen Präsidenten Putin erwartet
nun hat sich auch Joe Biden heute direkt
an Putin gewandt quasi hat gesagt er hat
sich verkalkuliert er weiß nicht was
Putin denkt aber auf jeden Fall denkt er
nicht mehr dass er die Ukraine einnehmen
kann wird sich das irgendwie morgen in
dieser Rede wieder spiegeln oder was
erwarten Sie von dieser Rede
das ist eine Rede auf die hier sehr
lange schon gewartet wird das ist die
Rede an die Nation an die föderale
Versammlung des Landes hat Putin lange
nicht mehr gemacht und alle warten
natürlich darauf dass er irgendwas zum
Krieg in der Ukraine sagt man rechnet
damit dass man hier möglicherweise
irgendwelche Erfolge verkündet dass man
vielleicht sogar verkündet man habe die
Stadt bachmut eingenommen ob das dann
nun stimmt oder nicht ist die nächste
Frage aber irgendwas muss Putin ja
präsentieren können manche erwarten auch
dass es da möglicherweise schlechte
Nachrichten gibt insofern als dass es
vielleicht eine neue
immobilienmachungskampagne geben könnte
oder ähnliches völlig ungewiss was da
kommt aber sicherlich ist beides Besuch
in Kiew Einschlag für Putin denn gerade
am Vorabend dieser Rede die er zum quasi
zum zum Tag des
vaterlandsverteidigers hier auch hält
das ist ja ein wichtiger Feiertag ein
ein Feiertag aller Soldatinnen Soldaten
das an diesem Tag oder am Vorabend
dieses Tages beiden nun tatsächlich in
der Ukraine ist in Kiew dass man hier
sich ursprünglicher mal ausgerechnet
hatte in wenigen Tagen einnehmen zu
können das ist natürlich erstmal ein
Schlag putin wird darauf sicherlich
nicht direkt reagieren auch das wäre
siehe erste Antwort eher untypisch aber
Sie müssen sich jetzt überlegen wie Sie
mit dieser Tatsache umgehen hier klar es
gibt ja heute noch einen ganz spannenden
Besuch in Moskau auch und zwar wangier
ist ja der oberste Außenpolitiker Chinas
der ist heute zu melden das zumindest
die Nachrichtenagenturen in Moskau
eingetroffen kann man irgendetwas von
diesem Besuch erwarten da gibt es ja auf
der einen Seite Meldung es gibt eine
neue Friedensinitiative Chinas auf der
anderen Seite hört man davon china will
jetzt doch Waffen liefern direkt an
Russland zur Unterstützung im Krieg
gegen die Ukraine was kann man da
erwarten
großes Rätselraten ehrlich gesagt um den
Besuch des chinesischen außenpolitikers
hier weil niemand so richtig genau sagt
was eigentlich ist wann es passiert ob
er schon hier ist oder nicht der Kreml
hat heute morgen verlautbaren lassen man
werde über das Datum und über die genaue
Zeit informieren dann hieß es wieder er
sei heute in der Stadt völlig unklar
dann hieß es er sei zum Ende seiner
europäischen Tournee in der Stadt manche
vermuten dass er möglicherweise sogar
als so eine Art überraschungs Ehrengast
morgen bei Putins Rede sitzen würde das
wäre dann wiederum ein sehr starkes
Zeichen ob China so weit geht schwer zu
sagen aber er hatte ja tatsächlich eine
Friedensinitiative oder eine
verhandlungsinitiative angekündigt
möglicherweise ist das der erste Schritt
den er hier geht völlig unklar wie
gesagt wir wissen nicht mal ob er schon
hier ist und wenn ja wenn nicht wann er
kommt also wirklich großes Rätselraten
wir müssen den heutigen Tag abwarten 1
Schätzungen von Ina rückt der Russlands
von dance in der ARD in Moskau nach dem
Besuch von Joe Biden in Kia vielen Dank
nach Moskau
und wir gehen jetzt direkt weiter nach
Kiew dort hat er ja der Besuch
stattgefunden von Joe Biden und ich
begrüße meinen Kollegen was wie die
gollott in Kiew
wie ist das aufgenommen worden in der
Hauptstadt in der Ukraine insgesamt
mit einer großen Überraschung es gab
gestern Abend erstmals Gerüchte darüber
dass ein solcher Besuch möglicherweise
anstehen konnte heute morgen
verdichteten sich diese Gerüchte als
viele zentrale Straßen in der Hauptstadt
abgesperrt wurden und zwar in einer Art
und Weise wie das bei keinem Besuch bei
keinem großen und wichtigen Besuch
bisher passiert ist dann kursierten
erste Videos von großen Autokolonnen bis
dann eben bekannt wurde dass Joe Biden
hier ist als er mit silenski einen
kleinen Spaziergang machte hier ganz in
der Nähe von madan an der St Michaels
Kathedrale da begann auch ein
Sirenenalarm das heißt der US-Präsident
hat selbst bei seinem Besuch gespürt was
diese russische Bedrohung was diese
Angriffskrieg bedeutet
wie waren denn die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen dort heute in
Kiew wird ja berichtet Mobilfunknetz sei
abgeschaltet gewesen und auf der anderen
Seite berichten sie jetzt gerade das
join sich da relativ frei bewegt hat
relativ frei aber wie gesagt das gab
große Absperrungen es gab gab große
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen wie ist das bei
keinem anderen Staats- und
Regierungschefs Chef in dieser Form
gegeben hat das heißt es ist ein ganz
anderes Level an Sicherheit dass wir
hier heute in Kiel beobachtet haben nun
hat ja schon beiden noch einiges
angekündigt heimasse
Raketen für die Bewaffnung der aus von
den USA bereits gelieferten
Raketenwerfer er hat noch mal
panzerbrechende Waffen angekündigt aber
es gibt natürlich zwei wichtige Punkte
das sind eben Raketen mit sehr langer
Reichweite 300 km beispielsweise und auf
der anderen Seite auch Kampfjets da
irgendwas drüber bekannt geworden immer
am Rande des Besuches vielleicht oder
auf eine der Pressekonferenzen
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt ist darüber
nichts bekannt aber Präsident selenski
hat angedeutet dass sie darüber
gesprochen haben Präsident selenski hat
auch angedeutet dass es in den kommenden
Tagen Informationen dazu geben könnte
gerade was die Raketen mit weiterer
Reichweite angeht aber eben noch nichts
Konkretes dieser Besuch hat eben diese
zwei Ebenen einerseits diese große
finanzielle Unterstützung von 500
Millionen US Dollar diese militärische
Unterstützung und zum anderen aber die
hohe Symbolkraft vor einem Jahr war es
die US-Regierung die gewarnt hat vor
einer russischen Invasion die diese
Informationen auch öffentlich machte und
das betonte beiden jetzt auch seinem
Besuch Putin wollte den Westen damit
Spalten dass sei ihm nicht gelungen und
auch die ersten Reaktion die ich aus der
Bevölkerung hier wahrnehme ist ein
großes Staunen und eine sehr positive
Wahrnehmung dieses Besuchs weil die
Menschen mir eben sagen wir werden hier
nicht vergessen das zeigt dieser Besuch
von Joe Biden
sind ja enge Bande zwischen den USA auf
der einen Seite und eben der Ukraine nun
jährt sich ja am 24 Februar also am
Freitag der Jahrestag der Invasion und
da ist ja die große Frage wie bereitet
man sich darauf vor befürchtet man da in
Kiew in der Ukraine noch mal verschärfte
Angriffe aus Russland
Kiew sagt wir gehen damit um also wir
hören nicht auf das was Russland sagt
wir reagieren darauf was Russland macht
Präsident selenski hat ja bereits gesagt
dass nach seiner Einschätzung die
russische Offensive bereits laufe und
ähm natürlich gibt es die Spekulation
auch gerade in der Bevölkerung das
größere Angriffe kommen könnten
umgekehrt beobachten wir jetzt schon
seit einigen Tagen Raketenangriffe auf
verschiedene Regionen des Landes es
werden Angriffe entlang der Frontlinie
wahrgenommen also es ist sozusagen
weiterhin die Realität in der Ukraine
ein Leben mit dem Krieg und ein Leben
mit der ständigen Bedrohung vor
russischen Angriffen kurze Frage nur zum
Schluss Herr gollotte und das habe ich
mich auch gefragt als ich die Meldung
heute bekam dass der Präsident dort vor
Ort ist wie ist er überhaupt in die
Ukraine gekommen und ist er inzwischen
schon wieder abgereist weiß man da was
drüber oder ist das alles strengstens
geheim
dazu kann ich keine seriöse Antwort
geben zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt und soweit
ich weiß könnte er noch hier sein aber
darüber kann ich zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
keine Auskunft geben ganz herzlichen
Dank für diese ganz aktuellen
Einschätzungen aus der Ukraine und
vielen Dank für die
Informationen die uns jetzt hier ja ganz
aktuell erreicht haben